l'enjeu le plus fondamental de notre
époque c'est l'écologie la question qui
me tah
et comment minimiser autant que possible
notre impact sur la planète centraux
entraver notre bien-être et aussi
paradoxal que cela peut paraître ma
réponse à moi c'est la ville la ville
dense paris londres singapour moscou et
l'innovation urbaine
la réinvention urbaine alors pourquoi il
va parce que la ville dense
en fait ça qu'on sent que individus donc
ça permet finalement de limiter notre
impact et notre emprise sur les
écosystèmes
puis en plus de ça ça ne gâche rien ça
concentrent les cerveaux et donc a
priori les bonnes idées ce qui a aussi
extrêmement intéressant avec les villes
c'est qu'elles se développent à huit est
complètement vertigineuse alors elle
concentre déjà à moitié de la population
mondiale en 2050 ce sera 70 % alors ça
peut peut-être vous paraître une un
évident à une évidence parce que vous
êtes français et qu'on est déjà
urbanisée à 80% mais qu'est ce que ça
veut dire 70% d'urbain en 2050
ça veut dire trois milliards d'individus
qui arrive en ville en l'espace de
trente ans 3 milliards d'individus
difficile d'imaginer ce que ça peut
représenter mais c'est comme s'ils
avaient une ville comme strasbourg qui
sortaient de terre tous les jours
pendant 30 ans prof de maths strasbourg
après demain strasbourg ou l'équivalent
d'une métropole parisienne qui
apparaîtrait tous les mois pendant 30
ans tous les mois du coup moi j'aimerais
bien vous expliquer aujourd'hui comment
j'en suis arrivée à cette réflexion et
comment est ce qu'on essaye de
réinventer un petit peu l'urbain de
manière à gilles à paris il ya quatre
ans j'ai décidé de partir voyager sans
prendre l'avion pendant six mois en
train bus auto stop à pied avec ce que
je trouvais j'ai traversé les quelques
kilomètres qui sépare l'océan atlantique
de la mer de chine
puis après j'ai acheté un vélo et j'ai
arpenté l'asie du sud-est à bicyclette
alors du coup sur ma route j'ai trouvé
quelques villes
paris moscou l'an batteur beijing
hanoi hô chi minh sanh châu ngoc rangoon
singapour pour la loupe pour et entre
chacune de ces villes des espaces assez
surprenant des rizières des montagnes
des campagnes des déserts des steppes
des espaces immenses ou services
commodités accès au savoir quand même
difficilement rendez vous et qui du coup
font des villes les espaces où se
concentrent des opportunités on trouve
tous au même endroit
le docteur le boulot le business la
religion la culture et centres de
décision ça grouille ça construit sa vie
24 heures sur 24 comme ici à hô chi minh
alors j'ai pas fais que me balader j'ai
aussi beaucoup appris et j'en retiens de
prise de conscience assez essentiel que
j'aimerais partager avec vous
aujourd'hui
la première c'est que les villes
s'étendent alors c'est même quelque
chose que j'ai vécue physiquement quand
il m'a fallu une journée entière non
journée pour sortir des périphéries de
hô chi minh
avec ma bicyclette des périphéries de
hanoi de bangkok
ça m'est aussi arrivé pour sortir du
grand paris alors pourquoi les villes
s'étendent pas parce que la
planification urbaine est un luxe j'ai
traversé des villes ou des bouts de
ville comme ici en inde où là le
cadastre n'existe pas rond où vous les
ruches les réseaux d'électricité les
réseaux d'eau les logements se
construisent de manière complètement
sauvages ou libre ça dépend un peu du
point de vue il ya pas de baron
haussmann qui sont passés par là tout
sort de terre
alors évidemment il ya quelques
conséquences négatives 1 par exemple la
création de zones de danger parce qu'on
n'a pas du tout réfléchi à pourquoi
est-ce qu'on construisait là comment
est-ce qu'on devait construire
je vous laisse imaginer ces câbles
électriques là en temps nous sont assez
le début de la mousson
on peut avoir de l'eau jusque là il ya
aussi des conséquences positives par
exemple le fait qu'on développe les
habitants développe des services qui
correspondent exactement à leurs besoins
parce que c'est eux qui les développent
c'est pour eux qui les développent une
appropriation aussi qui est très forte
une responsabilisation j'ai à ma charge
ce qui m'entoure à quoi ça ressemble
deuxième prise de conscience c'est que
les villes occidentales sont des villes
de vieux c'est d'ailleurs la chose qui
m'a le plus surprise quand je suis
rentré en france j'ai mis un peu de
temps à comprendre ce que c'était mais
en fait nos villes sont remplis de
personnes âgées
alors comment je me suis rendu compte en
fait par contraste parce que j'ai vécu
pendant plus d'un an dans des villes qui
étaient remplis de jeunes
alors qu'est ce que ça implique sa passe
à implique évidemment de construire des
villes qui soit avec des aménagements
spécifiques pour cette population
et puis ça remet un petit peu en cause
quand même notre capacité à concevoir la
ville de demain qui sera probablement
plutôt inventer en afrique ou en asie
alors j'ai pas juste observer ce voyage
aussi m'a permis de me faire des
convictions de me forger des convictions
extrêmement fortes sur sur l'urbain la
première conviction que je me suis forgé
je pense que vous commencez à comprendre
c'est que la densité est une bonne chose
alors évidemment je ne minimise pas tous
les travers d'une ville dense la
pollution le bruit la poussière mais
finalement c'est probablement la ville
temps c'est probablement la seule
solution qu'on a
pour limiter notre emprise sur les
écosystèmes 10 milliards d'individus à
nourrir habiller loger ça fait une
sacrée emprises foncières à caen vous y
pensez c'est du pur calcul
le pavillon de 300 mètres carrés
pour chaque famille ça paraît
difficilement soutenable juste pour se
loger ok la densité est une bonne chose
mais quelle densité
pour moi ce qu'il fait ville c'est la
densité d'activité est pas la densité de
béton je connais pas meilleur exemple
lacunes et pitau la nouvelle capitale
birmane
c'est une ville assez impressionnante
elle fait six fois lavé la taille de new
york
les infrastructures impressionnante
c'est parce que vous trouvez sur la
photo est par exemple des voies de
circulation qui font jusqu'à qui
permettent d'aligner jusqu'à 20 file de
véhicules imaginez pourtant sur ces
voies de circulation il est possible de
voir une charrette tirée par un âne
faire face au vide tout le contraire de
rangoun vibrante d'activité ou même de
ce petit village la du lac inle dans les
campagnes un jour de marché
on peut voir des embouteillages de canoë
hors du coup moi ça me fait dire qu'en
fait ce qui fait la ville depuis
toujours ce qui fait l'intérêt la
puissance et la richesse d'une ville
celle échanges économiques
c'est la diversité de services c'est le
maillage c'est la densité lien social
c'est l'échangé culturel et c'est la
facilité de naviguer de l'un à l'autre
deuxième conviction très forte c'est que
les zones les plus dynamiques
c'est les zones que se sont appropriés
les habitants c'est à dire les zones sur
lesquelles les habitants se sentent bien
se sentent à l'aise alors ça pourquoi
est ce que c'est important
et bien parce que c'est un pré requis si
on veut une ville dense car qui dit
ville dense dix petits habitats dit
besoin nécessité de vivre une partie
d'une partie de sa vie en dehors de chez
soi c'est d'ailleurs ce qui explique en
partie que paris est une ville si dense
si intéressante si vibrante et c'est
aussi ce qu'on retrouve est ce qu'on
ressent beaucoup à beijing
et c'est un vrai plaisir plaisir de voir
comme ici une compétition d'art martial
dans un parc plaisir de participer à un
concours de calligraphie à l'eau sur un
trottoir
ou plaisir de participer de s'immiscer
dans un cours de gym matinale le matin
dans la rue qu'est ce que ça veut dire
ça va du coup ça veut dire qu'il faut
qu'on crée des espaces publics dans
lesquels les gens se sentent à l'aise en
sécurité dépourvue du plus de
contraintes possibles par exemple des
espaces publics qu'ils soient des
poumons peut marcher peut-être sans
voitures qui viennent bloquer le flux
des changes entravé l'activité d'un bord
à l'autre
un peu comme ce qu'on a vu ce week-end
avec paris sans voiture voilà tout ça ça
me fait dire qu'il ya quand même encore
pas mal de choses à inventer pour à la
fois créer des villes plus dense pour
limiter notre impact est plus agréable
parce qu'il faut quand même les rendre
attractives mais aussi pour remettre au
centre les habitants au centre delà du
processus de décision et de et de et de
conception finalement parce que ce sont
eux par leurs activités leurs idées leur
appropriation de l'espace qui font la
ville et c'est ce que nous faisons à
paris par l'expérimentation urbaine
alors qu'est ce que c'est
l'expérimentation urbaine c'est le fait
de positionner sur l'espace urbain à la
merci de celui qui passe un produit ou
un service qui propose en tout cas sur
le papier une amélioration de la ville
et puis eva lui évalué surtout évaluer
si ça marche je vous propose quelques
les et quelques exemples c'est toujours
plus parlant commençons par les déchets
or qui dit concentration d'individus dit
forcément concentration de déchets
comment est ce qu'on fait pour traiter
toujours plus de déchets si possible en
réduisant le nombre de camions tant qu'à
faire on peut commencer déjà par les
déchets organiques vos restes de repas
les invendus alimentaire les déchets
végétaux
en fait c'est une mine d'or pourquoi
parce que par méthanisation peut
produire de l'énergie avec et puis par
compostage mais on peut créer du terreau
assez riche
il s'en servir pour autre chose
prenant compostage c'est assez
intéressant parce qu'il nous permet de
traiter les déchets de manière locale
l'année dernière on s'est dit qu'on
allait tester un système de compostage
électromécanique qui sur le papier nous
proposer de réduire énormément le temps
de compostage de réduire les nuisances
pratiquement sans aucune consommation
électrique
bref un peu le saint graal s'est dit bon
bah on va voir ce que ça donne donc on a
positionné on est parti avec une start
up qui s'appelle les alchimistes et on a
positionné leurs leur proposition de
composteurs électromécanique au grand
voisin dans le 14e arrondissement pour
voir ce que ça donnait alors qu'est ce
que ça a donné
banjo déjà ça nous a permis de composter
de traiter 7 tonnes de biodéchets
alors ça paraît petit 1 mais c'est
toujours ça de pris pour la collectivité
cas pas eu à le faire
et puis le propre de l'expérimentation
c'est de tester à petite échelle
ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'on a
observés comme ce qui était prévu sur le
papier aucune nuisance très peu de
nuisances olfactives pas d'arrivées de
rongeurs consommation électrique en
effet assez faible ce qui est
intéressant aussi c'est qu'on a quand
même produit cinq mètres cubes de
compost compost qui a pu être vendu
parce qu'il a passé tous les agréments
sanitaire grâce à l'expérimentation pour
pouvoir être vendus ce qui permet de
réfléchir complètement différemment
le modèle économique de ce type de
solutions et puis ce qui ne gâche rien
c'est que tous les flux des changes
que ce soit la collecte des déchets ou
la diffusion la distribution du compost
ont été faits par triporteur
prenons un autre exemple
ce parking entouré de tours verticales
sa aubervilliers alors c'est le parking
d'un foyer de jeunes travailleurs qui
fait aussi cantine pour à peu près tous
les salariés du quartier
alors ici il avait quelques problèmes de
sécurité pour les piétons est aussi un
gros effet d' îlots de chaleur urbains
qu'est ce que ça veut dire l'effet
d'îlot de chaleur urbains ça veut dire
que quand il fait chaud ici il fait très
très chaud
alors c'est vrai ici hein c'est vrai
dans plein d'endroits paris pour tout
vous dire météo france peut mesurer
jusqu'à 8 degrés de différence en temps
de canicule
entre paris et les zones moins
urbanisées autour 8 degrés alors les
locataires du site sont dit que ça
suffisait d'avoir 45 degrés dans l'or
dans leurs bureaux
l'été et puis qu'il fallait réaménager
repenser complètement l'espace pour en
faire une zone piétonne mais pas
n'importe comment
ils se sont associés avec le cabinet
d'architectes qui leur a proposé ça pour
structurer une démarche assez original
qui permet de combiner à la fois les
bienfaits de la forêt par exemple le
rafraîchissement ou l'ombre âge apporte
naturellement par les arbres et les
bienfaits de la ville l'accessibilité la
possibilité de faire du multi usages ils
ont pris tout projet sous ce prisme
ils ont par exemple essayer de répondre
essayait toujours de répondre à la
question peut-on faire un revêtement qui
absorbent l'eau de pluie et qui la
restitue en temps de chaleur
un peu comme si transpirait ce qui nous
permettrait d'avoir les avantages d'un
solde naturel et les avantages d'un sol
en dur alors nous on a décidé d'en faire
une zone pilote sur l'effet d'îlot de
chaleur par exemple avec un partenariat
avec météo france l'agencé parisienne du
climat et des thésards on a mis en place
un système de suivi des températures
avant pendant et après la transformation
du site pour voir ce que ça a donné
et l'objectif ici c'est de montrer que
l'aménagement peut avoir un impact
positif sur le climat en ville et
comprendre comment donc à faire
troisième exemple pour vous montrer un
petit peu la diversité de projets qu'on
accompagne ça ça répond à la question
que je faisais tout à l'heure constat
que je posais tout à l'heure sur la
population la population âgée en ville
alors comment fait on pour améliorer la
qualité de vie de cette population est
en même temps rompre leur isolement donc
beaucoup beaucoup souffrent ville lance
moment on est en train de tester dans le
xiiie arrondissement une solution de
conciergerie de quartier qui a développé
des services spécifiques et d'animations
pour cette population de personnes âgées
et en plus de ça elle a mis en place des
z et gestes des processus de
sensibilisation pour accompagner ces
personnes notamment dans les périodes un
peu complexes comme un grand froid ou
une canicule
alors là notre objectif c'est de montrer
que la ville comment est ce que la ville
peut devenir plus plus inclusive éviter
qu'elles oublient personnes est l'oubli
quelqu'un pardon dans son dans son
développement
maintenant je vous ai montré tous ces
exemples comment est-ce qu'on va
calculer comment est-ce qu'on va suivre
comment est-ce qu'on va conclure qu'une
expérimentation appris à marcher pas
dans le bon sens alors nous on regarde
cinq choses principalement la première
et c'est la plus importante c'est
l'appropriation par les usagers les
usagers ça peut être les touristes les
personnes âgées des habitants les
étudiants les travailleurs qui passe par
là l'appropriation ça veut dire que
c'est ces utilisateurs ont testé ce
qu'on leur a proposé ce que sont
appropriés le valide
peut-être même l'ont déjà détourné de
son usage initial et nous disent assez
top ça j'aimerais avoir ça dans mon
quartier
partout en dire que ça marche c'est à
dire aussi ça veut aussi dire que les
les impacts qui sont mesuré les impacts
positifs à son supérieur aux impacts
négatifs
va de soi mais pas toujours du bien de
le dire alors les impacts ça peut être
sur l'environnement sur l'inclusion sur
la résilience sur la qualité de vie dire
que ça marche ça veut dire que c'est
faisable
ça veut dire que les efforts qui sont
nécessaires et la complexité de mise en
oeuvre et bien à peu près
proportionnelle aux bénéfices qu'on en
retire un gros que ça vaut le coup dire
que ça marche c'est aussi dire que c'est
durable c'est à dire que c'est
reproductible qu'on sait qu'on a compris
qu'il y avait un modèle de développement
et que en plus de ça on perçoit que
quand on va changer d'échelle a priori
on ne verse pas les bénéfices enfin dire
que ça marche
c'est dire qu'on s'est donné le droit de
se tromper c'est dire qu'on a pris le
risque que ça ne marche pas et qu à ce
stade c'est pas grave c'est même plutôt
bénéfique parce qu'on a compris pourquoi
ça ne marchait pas et où ça bloquait je
vais conclure quand même je voulais
revenir à ma question initiale en fait
toutes ces solutions qu'on accompagne
moi elle me permettent aujourd'hui
d'être optimiste d'être profondément
optimiste sur notre capacité à vivre
plus nombreux et mieux en ville quel que
soit notre profil et ainsi réduire notre
emprise sur les autres écosystèmes
alors pourquoi les villes dans ce sens
est le meilleur endroit pour vivre parce
que finalement c'est la seule solution
qui nous permet de prendre soin est de
sauvegarder ce qui nous entoure
parce que ce sont des centres
d'opportunités et parce qu'on a tous les
ingrédients en tout cas moi je le vois
tous les jours pour en faire des centres
de bien-être et aujourd'hui il ne tient
plus qu à nous d'assumer et d'embrasser
cette densité agréable je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]